رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
الى وجوب العمل على شفاف فكره اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه وقطع الطريق امامها ان كان ذاك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
ما الرسائل التي ارادنياهو توجيهها بهذه
التصريحات الان والى من وما خيارات السلطه
الفلسطينيه تجاه ما كشفه نتنياهو بخصوص
الموقف من دوله فلسطينيه لو كيف ستستقبل
واشنطن دعوه اسرائيل لاجتثاب فكره اقامه
الدوله الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
الهدف من ناحيه نتنياهو في هذا الوقت
بعلاقه للظروف السياسيه قبال السوق
الفلسطينيه وتحت الرئيس محمود عباس
اذني العنوان او الهدف من ناحيته هو
الامريكان البيت الابيض
تحت رئيس جو بايدن او رئيس الجاي بعده
يرسل الرسائل ولا يعني لا يخفي وجهه خلف
قناعات عديده كما يفعل مع الاسرائيليين هو
واضح يعني عندما تحدث في
تهنئته لترامب عندما فاز بالانتخابات
الامريكيه تحدث معه ثم عاد الى الكنيست
وعندما رجع وعندما تم انتقاده قال انا لا
اتحدث عن دوله فلسطينيه انما اتحدث عن
دوله ناقصه يعني منزوعه الصلاحيات منزوعه
الدسم السياسي والامني والعسكري نتنياهو
على مر السنوات بالاضافه الى عدد كبير من
المستشارين من اليمين واقصى اليمين
يعتقدون انه لا يجب ان يكون هناك دوله
فلسطينيه وقد قالوا ذلك ذلك من قبل ولكن
ما من الرئيس مجلس وزراء اسرائيلي قال قبل
اليوم انه
ليس هناك حل دولتين
[موسيقى]
هي ماسه او رساله للقياده الفلسطينيه
الجايه كمان بعد ابو مازن انه من ناحيته
السلطه الفلسطينيه
بمختلف من
التصريحات تبع اليمين المتطرف داخل
الاعتراف انه ما في اي نيه او اي مصلحه
يصليه لانهيار كمان انهيار نسبي من ناحيته
لسكر الفلسطينيه موجوده في غملا ولازم
تبكي هناك بدون اي تغيير تعلم علم اليقين
حقيقه الاهداف والنوايا الاسرائيليه التي
ارسلها نتنياهو نتنياهو عندما يتحدث عن
هذا الموضوع يعني هو يفرق ويميز ويفصل بين
السلطه وبين الكيان الفلسطيني كدوله لانه
حسب الاتفاقيات الموقعه في اوسلو وفي
غيرها من الملاحق في كام ديفيد وغيرهم
يتحدثوا عن سلطه فلسطينيه بحكم ذاتي محدود
منزوع السلاح سلطه ان تفهم ما تدرك ان مده
اتفاقيه اوسلو انتهت
[موسيقى]
تعين على رئيس مجلس الوزراء ان يوضح اذا
ما عنا ان فكره حل الدولتين هي وراء
الجميع هذه فكره او معارضه لربما معناها
نتنياهو ليس بالحده التي تشير اليها
التقرير وسوف نكتشف لاحقا سياسه
بالنسبه
لموضوع فلسطين او لقضيه فلسطينيات
هي وصول الى
استقلال الحكومه الفلسطينيه بس مش وصول
الى دوله فلسطينيه هذا مش اشي جديد
وبموضوع دولتين حسب السياسه والفكره
الامريكيه
اذني
كمان الامريكان بيعرفوا انه هذه الفكره هي
مش واقعه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لن
تتخلى عن هذه الفكره والشركاء في منطقه
الخليج يصرون على هذه الفكره واعتقد ان
بنيامين نتنياهو يفهم انه لمصلحه اسرائيل
الاقتصاديه لمصلحه مستقبل اسرائيل لا
يمكنها ان تقطع هذه الصله التي تبنيها من
خلال اتفاقيات ابرهام